what's up sweet tits uh you gotta check
out my fall dates all on sale now at
salvolcanocomedy.com
we got uh toronto we have hamilton
canada ontario there richmond virginia
hershey pennsylvania second show added
knoxville uh atlanta second show added
birmingham louisville evansville
jacksonville tampa orlando sacramento
san jose santa rosa all on sale right
now savilecanoecomedy.com merch is up
there too uh yeah that's my next dates
and that's going to be it for a little
while so make sure you get out there
thanks guys
all right and then this head hey folks
joe derosa here from the taste buds
podcast i got dates i got dates i got
dates go to joederosainfo.com
to check them out you can also buy your
tickets there get all the show info you
need
first up atlantic city new jersey then i
will be heading off to san diego
california i am also hitting somerville
in massachusetts after that north
carolina
and some other stuff
joederosainfo.com new dates are being
added all the time and if you're in new
york city come to joey roses if you're
not in new york city and you want to
make a trip come to joey rose's joey
roses nyc joeyrosesnyc.com for all the
info on the spot that serves both
alcohol and sandwiches at amazing prices
opening tuesday through sunday at 12 p.m
every day
taste joeyrosesnyc.com they coming to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right
welcome to t a s t e b this is a very
special joe derosa birthday dish
look at this thank you tv for setting
this all up
we got it's just donald's birthday like
when you were little it was surprise
birthday to
you thank you happy birthday
to
you
happy birthday
dear joey ditch jerosa
happy birthday
to you
i just blew hot wax all over my finger
yeah it's going to be a good birthday
it's going to be a [ __ ] either i forgot
to make a wish what's wrong with you i
don't know i was just thinking about how
i can't drink this because it's ice
cream oh that's right don't worry i know
someone who can have it
um that looks so good
it does look good i love it she even got
the red uh the red and yellow candles
this is awesome that's great thank you
vee thank you pimp all right come on out
ronald
that would have been crazy we had an
x-rated show like ronald and grimace
came out like infer like furries and
like did something to each other donkey
show
we got you a grimace show
i just realized chris chris could be a
good ronald mcdonald he picture chris in
the makeup it looks right doesn't it
yeah i can see that yeah that's amazing
this is so this is oh that's a great
thing to do for halloween that would be
a good one right just like 30 round
mcdonald's
that's good it's creepy especially this
yeah
um
to push you right i got the taste bud
socks on yes but you can't see the table
okay so and that was the limited edition
new york it's my first public wear of it
whoa
nice dude yeah i love it it's a great
shirt uh merch is available for taste
buds and everything else on our websites
this was all a surprise i didn't know
anybody was doing this i was very
touched this is the closest to a
surprise party i've ever had
i've never had a surprise party you've
never had a surprise for you i've had a
few in my life a few i mean i'm
[Laughter]
four years oh wait i was part of the
ratio isn't that big
the ratio is not that much because i'm
alive a long time now
i had a 37th surprise that was a huge
one we had a yacht rock band it was like
a big one there was like hoops
foods who planned it fringe uh my my no
my my gal
that's i think why i've never had one
i've never had a steady gap
i think that's how
when i was little my parents threw me
one my parents threw me three
in my life i remember one when i was
like i think probably somewhere around
19 18 and then i had one as a kid i
remember that one and then uh yeah
there's been a few i
my parents never could have
planned a surprise party for me as a kid
because of my utter demand
that a party be thrown
for me as a child yeah you can't demand
a surprise party no i'm saying like i
they didn't have a chance to plan a
surprise party because i was talking
about my birthday in the party
months beforehand ah so you you they
never circumvented it yeah they never
could have done you usurped it yeah
because then they said we're not going
to let you have a party there would have
been issues i think
if i'm being honest
god said you saw it i'm not proud of
that you started to plan the party and
then they had no no choice but to go
forth with that party yeah yeah
yeah and like around you do plan parties
because every year you you letter you do
you're on top of it you're like don't
forget block this out it's my birthday i
love that yeah well well that's the
thing
as a child i would have said to my
parents if i had the means to do this
myself i would
but i don't right so i'm going to need
the two of you to take care of it i'm
thinking batman this year
we need this tv show young derozan yeah
oh my god like young sheldon
so
oh my god like a picture if it's like a
sick comic a picture what the intro is
like like the song and him sitting in
the ditch and stuff
you know
we get one of the stranger things kids
yeah yeah it cuts to the birthday party
it's him alone in a bath suit
the players were well attended
they're always well attended it was the
sleeper neighborhood hit of the season
this is also so this was sort of like a
present that it just showed up this time
roger beck sent us he's an artist
what are we about to get
uh
he sent us
shirts uh v i don't think there's one
here for you i'm sorry
it's k it's packages pimp
there's yours
here's mine no
no
so he designed the sesame
and he says hey guys i hope you enjoy
the care package i'm sorry if i got the
shirt sizes wrong
i meant
very generous giving me a medium very
generous
he gave you a
mead because i got a large i was like
now i okay
i mentioned to this i mentioned this to
pimp in a message but i'd love to create
the taste buds cereal box if you're
interested
why wouldn't we be i mean sure
yeah what the waiting for roger get on
it let's go
yeah
uh thanks for keeping me entertained
love the pod keep up with the great work
love from toronto one of my favorite
cities in the world show the camps in
october bec come on out
that's great
that's awesome oh my god i didn't even
notice the detail we're wearing our
shirts unbelievable
look i'm wearing my wrestlemania shirt
and you're wearing your wu tang shirt
back reach reach out to uh
or what's our what's our what's our
email address
and hit us up i'll get you tickets for
toronto uh love from toronto roger at
roger james you can follow roger he's an
amazing artist this is wonderful can you
pass that to v for like our archives
so then also
big shout outs
these came on the same dude can you
believe i've been collecting stickers
again you know this is down sorry i've
been collecting stickers again recently
because i put it on my wii box there's
pins in here
i see pins too this guy's awesome she's
louise my friend uh jane james pink
stone who you've met sal we had a big
day in the city with him do you remember
that
do you remember that or no
your friend yeah yeah of course yeah
yeah um he collects he collects old um
remember those stickers you got on the
machines the horror movie stickers that
were like
if you turned them it was like not that
they moved they had like the silver
you know what i'm talking about the
movie stickers they had like the
silverish like tint to them
and they had like prism colors and 100
they were like foil stickers that like
get glimmered he collects we also see
that i'll bring that up later i'll bring
that up he collects those and he's got
the
the second biggest collection in the
world he was how does he know that
because he he's like in collector groups
and stuff and they compare collections
and stuff like that
and it's wow really this data data
gathering and processing i mean it's on
adult sticker collections i didn't
challenge him too hard on the claim
it's such a it's so specific such a
niche weird one of the biggest
collections but second which is the guy
that roams the earth that's first how
many more house houses how many stickers
short is he from the first pearly price
i think only one or two hold on
according to fish the largest well this
is collection of stickers
he's talking collection of prism
stickers this is a specifically no this
he's a substitute right he's a subject
this is this dude who has the most of
them
uh at least as of nine years ago
nine years ago he was the world record
holder and uh i don't want to butcher
his name nidhi
bansal
uh 102 317
to the sticker by the way they counted
someone sat there from guinness
imagine that like you're you work for
guinness and we're like all right we got
one for you today you're like yes what
am i gonna see the world's longest neck
am i gonna see you know am i gonna see
the biggest uh you know uh vintage
pornography collection what am i gonna
say no you're gonna count
102 317 stickers and then you got to
recount it yeah because it's like the
walk of fame where you just pay for it
i think you have to qualify and then
then pay for it
um also shout outs speaking of stickers
to charital comics
uh turtle comics
this guy does great work too really
interesting but he's got a kickstarter
right now i think it's cool you know
what i for a split second i actually
thought do you remember when i went on a
scavenger hunt yeah and there was like
is it funny
yeah
you remember tuesday
when i was doing my scavy hunts um
i i got a clue and i thought it had to
do somehow another i linked it to
chortle comics and i followed them for a
second because i was gonna write them to
see and then i realized it was the wrong
clue and i unfollowed them but i didn't
realize you knew that follow him i
didn't realize you knew him yeah i
didn't realize he's doing comic book
he's trying to launch a line of comic
books based on all of us
who's all of us what do you mean all of
us his first comic that he's launching
is called hoagie and it's based on me
and i play a man that wears a hoagie
suit everywhere this is kidding me no
i'm not kidding
he's raising money for it there you go
he's raising money to make a comic about
you as a hoagie he's got a kickstarter
campaign
what did what did hoagy say to his
lawyer
please man you got to help me
but yeah look issue
issue number one hoagie oh my god
it's wild wait what
what what are you you look demonized
there i'm like a guy that dresses i
haven't read it yet because it's i i
don't have a copy yet wait do you do you
have a personal relationship with him no
he just started sending me stuff and he
was like i wanna
you don't know him
personally no i know him through uh
instagram odd series of events it is
it looks awesome oh this is a a book uh
what do you call as a page what do you
call those things a bookmark bookmark
yeah yeah but he's dope july 19th oh no
that he made that poster hold on that's
the wrong thing yeah look
here's the oh indiegogo i'm sorry not
nothing what does he design why don't
you design a shirt for us
he i'm sure he should see if bex would
will let us
if he'll
let us sell this as a shirt or maybe we
could just work something out with them
or this guy here indycogo campaign he's
trying to raise 20 grand he's got about
a thousand raised so he's got a little
ways to go
but help the kid out
he's got 95 percent of the way to go
help the kid but but we they didn't
there's a video there he sent me he sent
me pages that he's drawing
thousand dollars you can get a kia for
that
he sent me
you guys want one episode of joe as a
hoagie or does somebody want a what's
what's the nice sedan let's support the
kids no i know so like
i'm sure 20 000 is what it costs these
days do you get final say like what if
your character starts i don't know
i i i could care less
i said that what if yeah what if your
character is not all you think it's
cracked up to me she sent me some of the
pages that look fine and i said to him i
go look he goes do you can i get your
book if you're a jared
oh
fogleton
god it's all hoax no he goes can i get
your blessing and i go dude as long as
you're not saying any crazy racist [ __ ]
or whatever yeah you got my blessing so
you in the comic you're not hoagy you're
joe derosa as hoagy i i believe sean
dressed in a hoagie shoot kind of like
tim in what's his face in the hot dog
shoot oh in robinson yeah yeah you know
i think you should leave yeah shout out
tim robinson but go to uh sandwiches i
think you should leave support the
chortle comics campaign on indiegogo and
help him get these comics made he sent
me pictures of other people
i'm trying to find them of other
comedians
look he sent me togi tattoos i got
hoagie tattoos in here
temp tattoos no you don't i mean i want
a hoagie attempt tattoo immediately i'll
give it to you what do you mean look
here's pages from the thing there's
hoagie temp tattoos in here yeah wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
a minute wait a minute you can make we
can look here
chris we have to get temporary tattoos
for our merch here's chris and and the
chris uh pimp and the pig
yeah it's you and stefano in a field of
pigs in a comic book
yes i'm telling you i love this how does
who is he marketing the comic to though
to comedy fans who the hell do you think
he's marketing oh so the comic book is
gonna be marketed to comedy fans yeah
here's one of christchurch as a bear
like he's he's trying to do a line of
comments oh that's the 20 grand isn't i
don't think it's just for mine he's
trying to get this series started where
he can make these comics that are based
on comedians and like
their lives and their humor
and
it's all elevated and exaggerated so
like i'm a guy that wears a hoagie suit
because i have a hoagie shop
dresses as a bear in his right on the
nose chris is hanging out with pigs
this is um you got googly eyes in here
too yeah
wait where where is the uh where's the
tattoo the things are the hoagies the
pictures the little cards with hoagies i
think are temp tattoos
because he sent me a picture of that yes
take some of them oh it's just of a
hoagie though not of you
but honestly if we can make temptations
i want a real tattoo of a hoagie if we
can make 10 tattoos for merch want to
get tastebud tattoos
i'll get a real one
want to get them i'll get a taste yeah
you'll get a real taste bud tattoo yeah
i'll get 100 get it yeah i got to think
about what it is but yeah 100 i'll get
it that's fun we should get merch we
should get 10 tattoos for merch i love
it
yeah let's do it but there is one thing
i'm dying to know how did your road trip
go i don't think anyone knows about your
trip let's start from the beginning
first of all happy birthday thank you as
i approached my 45th birthday i i bought
a new car
in la and decided to drive it home
uh which was amazing
oh you know what else is weird hold on
so joe decides to buy
whoa whoa
you know what else is weird
this toy
so thor how is that wait wait don't open
it don't open it which one okay i'm not
gonna open mine open yours i'll tell you
why why you're not gonna open yours is
it a collective i'll tell you why
another weird coincidence when i was in
san francisco which was the beginning of
the trip
after one of the shows a taste buds fan
she came up to me and she gave me one of
these toys and it was of thor
and she goes this is from a mcdonald's
happy meal i know you love mcdonald's
this is for you and she gave it to me
and i kept it and i have it in my house
now and
i'm not going to open this because i
didn't open that one i'm going to see if
i can get all of them
you're falling right into their hands
well you're going to collect them all
you know this is a some type of a ram
or a bull are these things everything
they look like my little ponies i don't
know how they're from the thor universe
there's a few like really old ones i
still have my alf burger king-ish
from uh alf did a big burger king promo
in like the
i want to call it the late 80s early 90s
ish there's puppets there was all this
stuff yeah all the alpha puppies yeah
one said rock and roll
oh check this out the 15 most expensive
happy meal toys for mcdonald's let's see
it pimp
15.
1983.
the hot wheels that came out in 1983
there's 14 of them
uh cars and all okay
okay
has to be the value of 40 dollars okay
so you can save this for exactly 40
years joe and it'll get up to 40 bucks
clone wars happy meal box okay
star wars is at 50
okay
transforming food
70 beans oh that's cool
i had those
oh the oh that i thought it would be
transformers they're not they are
they're called changeables yeah but they
turn into robots they do yeah wait wait
i had those
i think i still have one of them what
are you talking about bro i don't know
where do you see where do you see that
they're transformers they transform into
robots
they're just not the brains hot cakes
remember what mcnuggets came in the
yellow styrofoam yeah with a
potato head kids 1987.
100 all right 100 clams
they're going up
minions been around for nine years
already
yeah wow the minion is 120
okay
furby
whoa
you [ __ ] with furbies
i [ __ ] with furbys you did right yeah
yeah hell yeah they were hot for a
second i remember my my niece or my
sister or somebody had him had one
remember tamagotchi
that was crack yeah that was crack yeah
i don't know my sister used to have
tamagotchi and she used to neglect them
and i just have to like i used to be
having anxiety about the goddamn
tomatoes
you've been with so much your sister's
tortured you did what's the tamagotchi
tamagotchi was like that little thing
you put on like a key ring it was like a
little screen
like a what do you call it
a digital pet and you had to feed it and
clean it and bathe it and all that jazz
and it would grow or could it could die
you could bathe it i think you had to do
i think you had to do all the all the
the things to it it's weird
maybe maybe maybe maybe you didn't bathe
it maybe you washed it or hosed it down
or maybe you didn't wait a minute did
you have a pet rock you have to keeling
up its crap did anybody have a pet rock
i didn't buy one but i had like one like
i remember when it came out though or
you made your own pepper that's good the
uh fraggle rock i had these let's see
what these are worth
i think i had these
wow
wait 92 no i didn't that was too old at
that point inspector gadget oh the the
the matthew broderick yeah
live action inspector guys worth 350.
who's paying who's paying not that money
for that collectors
toy collectors yeah but i don't give a
[ __ ] like
you're not a collector
you're not a collector yeah but my one
of my closest friends is a collector
he's not paying 350 for that
wow dude the happy one was out in 79
wow
underwater monsters oh did those things
expand i think so yep
400
i didn't know that happy meal came out
in 79 what year was the happy meal
invented pimp
beanie babies 450 dollars number one of
all time
did beanie babies still hold their value
or did that whole thing go kaput i think
it's like bitcoin
like they were valuable and then that
that's it
market dictates you know 79. like the
people that were spending their
mortgages on one of the hot mustards in
that bag are they are they like in bad
shape right now
i would say so if i guess
yeah people love those [ __ ] things
you guys if any of you collected beanie
babies
write in the comments uh right now
let us know if they're still worth
something what your most valuable one is
if if at all if it all imploded is
beanie baby still a thing
here you go family ruined by 100k beanie
baby investment what did it say
oh it's honey mustard those bastards i
thought it was hot mustard
on your birthday how's the food how's
the food
it's [ __ ] great
it's mcdonald's
oh of course you know if you haven't
eaten cheese
you know why we got mcdonald's
this has a cheeseburger in it all right
so what what do you have your favorite
joe's happy place this is it joe's
favorite place on earth is mcdonald's
yes so that's why vanity did point out
he asked for this on air he wanted this
party
yeah yeah no we couldn't we could have
surprised you with it but you demanded
it
they did surprise me with it yeah
because when we talked about it we said
we were going to go to a bar
and hire men to dress up as the
character yeah that's right yeah which
which was would have been interesting
all right weekend's just starting
yeah slices yeah
the uh
i know i i gotta say i don't approve
that mcdonald's doing this the apple
slices as if that's a farce to me
why because it's it's we know what it is
like we know what we're doing here why
are you putting apple slices into the
box
they did that because they had to for it
to pass as something they're trying to
get they're trying to get other people
in there and buying stuff off the menu i
don't think they're trying to get
anybody in are they trying to appease
the i think they're like legally we have
to do this so we can say children can
eat this right
so what happened on the road man what'd
you learn
wait start from the beginning you flew
to california decided out there that
you're going to buy a brand new first of
all your jeep what happened to the jeep
the jeep
you know it's look it's it works and
it's fine it's just you still have it
i'm selling i'm in the process of
selling it
it just requires a certain amount of
upkeep and after a while i was just like
i can't do this anymore like i'm not
like where is it being housed the jeep
right now i have it at my mom's house
in fact would you put it in a local
paper in fact the mechanic that i take
it to for upkeep today was like oh
you're selling it i'm actually
interested
which is great but
but anyway
um i don't know we'll see you know but
um but my my point is is i wanted
something more reliable i had paid
for
outright for the jeep i got a good deal
on it during the lockdown because of the
lockdown
and so when i left for la i was like
when i get back first order businesses i
got to get a new car
i was out in l.a doing shows and stuff i
went to san fran first
and
i found myself at a ford dealership and
i saw
a car that i really wanted
how did you find yourself that one i
went past one and they had the car i was
looking for and i said i'm not gonna be
able to find that in in new york and
that's it i'm gonna buy it what can you
find in new york because it's there it's
the new broncos and they're very hard to
come by only in l.a uh
it only happens in l.a or they're only
hard to come by now i'm just like you
know only in new york oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
i was like i can move a few things
around like i i'm open enough that i can
do a road trip and i did the balls it
takes
to be on vacation or work for a
temporary it was a work that was a work
trip
but you were 100 on the opposite side of
the country yes and you decided to buy
not lisa rent buy
a new car i couldn't lease it because i
didn't live there yeah you immediately
drive it back yeah oh you can't lease
out of state no sure you can i've done
it in jersey yeah well maybe in jersey
in california you can't do it
it's a california law i went to three
dealerships to make sure you're in
california i went to three dealerships
to make sure they weren't here
yeah
because there was all these dealerships
so you did compare money
no no i just how'd you know you got a
good deal
because i made them
i mean dude i'm a promise i'm a pain in
the ass dude like
with [ __ ] like that i asked question
after quest like i made them sit there
they were like well here's the blue book
value i go
no offense but i'm i'm good at it like
i'm nice about it but i go no offense
you seem like a good guy i want you to
you stole him yeah
i want you to show me the blue book
website
where it says that and he was like what
do you mean it's and i go no no you
handed me a piece of paper that says
that
i mean i could have made this show to me
i just did a lot of that and what
happened did you check it out yeah he
showed it to me so it did check out off
the paper yeah oh so you took him to
task for nothing yeah but i didn't i
said it in a way where i go i go put
yourself in my shoes you understand he's
like dude i get it don't worry about it
but i asked
i i i was there for a long time
and also too in my past i will say this
in my past car buying experiences
they said certain things that
were tip-offs to me
this was the main one
that they weren't [ __ ] around do you
think someone's been tipped off
tipped off you know seinfeld that's
something yeah
this was the main one they said
so these broncos are hard to find right
the guy was like
the whole time he was just like hey man
like it's a great car and you seem to
like it like
i don't know like i think it'd be cool
if we could figure something out like
and that's he left it at that okay
i can't tell you how many [ __ ] cars
when i've gone to the dealership they
don't let you go the one sentence they
say is
do what you want i mean this thing will
be gone to they all say that this is a
car that in fact would have been gone as
it was parked
they had to take it off a ramp they had
it on like a display ramp after i test
drove it as it was parked outside
and he was starting to work people were
circling it
and i was like dude dude people are
looking at and he was like i got the key
don't worry it's ours don't worry but
you know like but like
that's the one time in my life where
salesman could have said it at applied
pressure
and it would have been a thousand
percent true
and the fact that he didn't meant two
things number one the car actually is in
demand he doesn't have to do that and
number two
he wasn't [ __ ] with me he was just
like dude this is what it is what was
the price and they they worked with me i
got the pr how much did you still hang
on how much would you say you got it
down
uh thousands of dollars thousands from
the original price they gave you
100 got it down thousands of dollars did
he have to go back and talk to the
manager
the guy he was talking to he was letting
me talk to
and then i started talking to that guy
was this a bronco dealership is that is
that a thing it's a force a ford
dealership okay mm-hmm i mean
that's like
that's like me calling like new
brunswick estate right it's like i did
that thing where i called the city of
the state you go to mcdonald's you go is
this a quarter pounder
it's a mcdonald's sir so
and bronco was your vibe yeah
what what what about the bronco first of
all the new one is super cool i want an
old one
i want an old one that's what started me
i wanted an old one then they came out
and but my thing with the old ones was
i mean you want to talk upkeep i was
like i have no idea how to take care of
a bronco that old because the ones that
look cool were the ones from the 70s or
earlier yeah to be fair i was trying to
get a refurb like a old body but
refurbished right and that costs a lot
of money and then they came out with the
new ones i was like holy [ __ ] that looks
like the old ones but it's a new car and
then i was like i was driving i was
sprung
it's the best car i've ever owned really
it's amazing you had fun driving across
the country yeah dude to all the people
that wants to eat on the show
your wishes are coming true now tell me
if you tell me like after this episode
dude i i slept in it two nights
two of them star
mcdonald's mcdonald's
two of the nights i slept in it
[Laughter]
why
because i wanted to
because that's part of the adventure
you can't go on a road trip here's
here's elements of a road trip you ready
first of all you can't go on a road trip
and what not sleep in your car yeah no
you can't yes are you insane what a
crazy thing to say that's not crazy most
people that go on road trips do not
sleep in there here are the elements of
a road trip ready yeah folks
come on let's level
and when we level
we talk about dave
we've all been not a guy by the way a
sponsor dave uh we've all been in a
situation at some point where you know
look you're tight on cash all right it
could be for gas money
or day-to-day stuff uh it could be
that you need to buy a big purchase uh
for maybe
you're going to a wedding you need some
cash to get that wedding gift maybe it's
a person you love quite a bit you don't
want to show up empty-handed whatever
maybe it's for you maybe it's for
somebody else but sometimes you need
some cash and that's where dave
can help if you're living paycheck to
paycheck all right you're struggling to
make ends meet it can be really
stressful i've been there i've been in
situations where
you don't have a lot of fluid cash on
hand and all and i get it
i get the perspective of hey
well if i don't have cash on hand then
what am i worrying about you know buying
things for other people or whatever
it's not the point don't get hung up on
the specifics the the the point is is
you got to live your life and sometimes
that involves having to contribute to
somebody else's and sometimes that has
to do with contributing to your own
either way
sometimes a little extra cash can help
and dave that's more money to fill the
tank buy the gift catch up on bills
whatever again it could be for you it
could be for somebody else it could be
to help somebody else could be to help
yourself it could be for all of you
there's no interest
and there's no credit check needed
millions of people have already
downloaded the dave app to get the
financial relief they need with extra
cash and if you're in a pinch you need
some help download dave and get a
helping hand
all right so download the app from the
app store right now that's d-a-v-e
d-a-v-e sign up for an extra cash
account get up to 500 instantly for
terms and conditions go to dave.com
legal
instant transfer fees apply banking is
provided by evolve
member fdic
the future you will thank you for your
summer travels folks are you traveling
around some people take trips in the
summer summer's trip time i know it
doesn't have to be it could be any
season but it's summer and it's summer's
trip time and you know what i mean let's
talk babel maybe you're going to a place
where they're speaking a language that
you do not speak that's where babel
could help babel is addictively fun and
easy to learn a foreign language because
they have bite-sized language lessons
so you got some time now to learn a new
language that's great with babel you
only need 10 minutes to complete a
lesson so you can start having real-life
conversations in a new language in as
little as three weeks i have a friend
who is talking about moving out of the
united states permanently as many people
are these days and she said she doesn't
want to go
uh until she could learn the language of
the country she'd moved to and i said
well try babble
that's how you're going to learn it
quick if you want to get the hell out of
here you better move quick babel can
help
other learning language apps they use ai
for their lesson plans but babel
these lessons were created by over 150
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective
you can choose from 14 different
languages include including spanish
french italian and german so right now
save up to 60 off your subscription when
you go to babble.com taste buds that's
babel.com
buds for up to 60 off your subscription
babble language for
life
random hotels
crashing with friends
staying in the car a couple nights or
camping one of one of those two i know
what you mean it was too hot to camp i
would have camped i would have bought a
[ __ ] temp and camped wait wait but it
was so [ __ ] hot i was like where did
you find a place to pull also it's the
summer you you slept with the car
air conditioned well i it was at night
it was very very late at night when i
pulled over to sleep i'm talking like 4
00 a.m
so the car was cool enough because i'd
been driving for a while
where did you pull and then it didn't
get too hot where did you pull over that
you were safe and the windows are tinted
too a truck stops pull the truck stop
what the [ __ ] gonna happen
it's an adventure
you can't have a calculated adventure
you can't i had bad experiences out
there had amazing experiences the whole
thing was everything i could have wanted
dude i saw i saw the sunset in kansas it
was the most beautiful thing i've ever
seen in my life
i drove up into the mountains of utah to
watch a sunset i mean it's life-changing
[ __ ]
i drove through i drove through a major
[ __ ] storm i drove through a major
[ __ ] storm in kansas in pitch
black dude where all you could see in
front of right ahead of you was
lightning touching down
hundreds of miles now were you nervous
are you like [ __ ] yeah i'm in the
broncos i'm terrified
i was i felt safer because i had
four-wheel drive and everything and i
was like yeah i was like okay dude as
long as you pay attention like you'll be
okay but i was terrified dude you
couldn't see i'm not exaggerating in any
direction you looked you could not see
past your headlights i was like anything
could be out there right now anything i
couldn't see the edge of the road that's
how dark it was this doesn't sound smart
it also was just that's what an
adventure it was a brand new car also
i got it i got a 2021 but it only had 13
000 miles on it so it wasn't so you it
was broken in a little bit okay a little
bit okay okay so what's the morning
routine on this road trip what does
oh you know what you also just put that
many miles on it yourself yeah who cares
what's it was 3 000 and change or
something like that but off the off the
bat babe but it already had third it was
i'm saying had it had they driven it off
the lot with two miles on it i might
have been you've got more miles on the
way to do it is a cross-country trip on
the city of pants
live a little what are we doing here
we're on this planet to have you know
this is it i want to have an experience
yeah why if i can't put three thousand
miles on a [ __ ] ford bronco what car
can i put three thousand points what am
i gonna do people always stress the
mileage you gotta keep it down you gotta
put this
kia soul that's the car to do it with
but when you're trying to flip it if you
have those like 200 000 miles you're not
gonna get what you want i don't think
i'll ever flip it i think i will drive
it until it's done
and and then that'll be that wow
it's not the
it's not a kind it's not in my opinion
so far it's not the kind of car you flip
it's the kind of car you go
i'll i'll i'll bring it up to the
mountains and stash it there for when i
go up to the to the lake house or
whatever which hopefully by that i'll
have
some sort of property to my name so yeah
i told you
you said you were gonna buy a house now
you just bought a truck instead well i
yeah i financed it i didn't i didn't go
in and plop down the mic okay whatever
but so so so when
okay so
okay you're pulling out of la you put on
your blinker do you know where you how
often did you know where you were going
and how often were you like let me
decide where to go while i'm driving it
was when i left la
all i knew was
my first stop is gonna be vegas i can
get as far as vegas tonight
my friend amy lives there
i texted her no she doesn't
i texted her i said i'm coming in
are you around she's like yeah i go okay
i'm making my first stop in vegas i'll
see you there
i'll come i'll say hi we'll get dinner
and then i'll figure out what i'm doing
next after that wait for me
and she said okay
and that's what i did and we went out to
dinner and i was debating on if i wanted
to spend the night in vegas because part
of me wanted to like
go to old vegas and like
maybe crash in a casino for a night and
like whatever and then i was like
nah it's probably not a great way to
start the trip
is by like drinking 27 free whiskies as
i gamble money away and i'm gonna
probably need cut two like five hours
later joe's in like a texas hold'em game
and he throws the keys to the bronco in
the middle did you ever see uh lost in
america
that's the other reason i didn't do it
why do i know what that sound was it's
an albert brooks movie oh yeah yeah
so so lost america is about it's an
albert brooks movie where two yuppies
that live in la
they get they give up their entire they
liquidate everything so they can drop
out of society
and the first stop they make on that
they buy an rv that they're gonna live
in and the first stop they make is vegas
and while he's asleep the wife
gets like into a gambling craze and
gambles everything away it's one of the
funniest movies ever i gotta give it a
re-watch i saw it there's there's an
amazing scene albert brooks plays an
advertising exec there's an amazing
scene where he
gary marshall plays the casino the head
of the casino gary marshall
and albert brooks at four o'clock in the
morning his pajamas pitches to him he's
like i've got a great idea you give us
the money back
it'll be great
and carrie marshall
my favorite line is gary marshall goes
okay that's enough now you're a nice guy
you made me laugh and everything i'll
see you later
but uh but that was going through my
head
because so you didn't even stay in vegas
well no because because the the thing
his wife says that makes them stay when
they're teetering on should we do this
or not
she goes i know we're supposed to drop
out but just one last night in a big
hotel room and that's what i was
thinking and i was like
that's a bad way to start the trip
so i go listen i'm gonna keep going you
informed your trip from a 40 year old
movie
yeah
so
i said look we got dinner and i was like
alright i'm going to keep going
and she's like all right where are you
going i go well looks like i'm going
through utah she was like okay get to
moab
and i was like all right i won't make it
to moab tonight but i can get as far as
beaver
so she's like all right she goes book
your hotel now i go
it'll be fine like beaver's not like a
crazy city
there's tons of hotels there i'm looking
at them right now they all have
availability i'll be okay i get to
beaver
none of them had availability
oh no none what were you looking at dude
i was calling everything i was calling
everything but you said there was plenty
of availability
yeah the turns out the internet was
wrong
i don't know what was how could that be
possible i don't know what was going on
beaver dude it was packed it was packed
with stuff right
well there's all the tourist routes and
there's like buses of tourists that just
pull up and they'll take why the beaver
though it's probably on the way to the
grand canyon or
by the way folks this might turn into a
two-part episode let's warn everybody
now so nobody gets mad if that's what
happens
but i don't want to rush the story it's
a good story no i'm into it so anyway
so i get the beaver i'm calling place
after place everyone's like we're sorry
sir we're and i'm like
i'm now i'm starting to freak out and
i'm like oh my god did i make a huge
mistake
right
stuck in beaver
so i call a super eight
no and the guy hold on hold on you don't
need friends you don't even know you
don't even know dude you don't even i
don't even call it that's great i don't
even call it i just drive through the
night i was down to the last two hotels
i called a super eight
and the guy goes yeah we have rooms how
much he goes 279 dollars right i would
have i was i would have drove there just
just to go into the lobby up to the
front desk and told him to go [ __ ]
himself i was so mad i would have drove
that then i called another place called
the western inn
i think i was going to west
no
no no no no
i think it was called the westerner
is this also the goddamn straw it's a
straw actually like a spoon you're
supposed to suck it through a large
square straw
yeah that means
kudos but i mean like i'm not gonna and
it's got an air hole look it's got a
carb on it
nice like a bong
on the front of the straw what do you do
with that
i don't know
try it
you go scuba diving wait the what
there's more than one hole
there's a hole here right here you go
snorkeling why is that the hole in it
though
oh okay yeah
but but wait they but then the straw
won't work because it's got a hole in it
i don't think this is a straw bro oh
it's just a spoon so then why is it this
big square spoon with two holes in it
v saying the machine goes into it
how is that good
it's fair
fair wow
all right
i had a cookies and cream shake from
ralph isis two nights ago i mean yeah
come on dude i'm not i mean not no
offense donald
did you see wendy's has a strawberry
smoothie now
strawberry
frosty raw seed yeah pretty cool right
it's about damn time i never liked the
chocolate frosting but the strawberry
one intrigues me it's about down time
so
i go to this place
i believe it was called the western end
i'm like do you have rooms guys like
yeah it's bed bug city but i go great
how much he's like
70 bucks or whatever i was like i'll
take it very nice guy
sends me to the room
the room had um
two lamps
on end tables on either side of the bed
that were not plugged in because there
were no outlets they were just there oh
i mean we travel a lot
not to interrupt you but apropos here
is it me
or is it a challenge to find how to turn
on every goddamn light in every single
hotel you ever get to a hotel room all
right let's get some lights on
and then okay one one lamps you never
inevitably unplugged then one lamp you
look for a little black knob it's not
there then you're like look for it on
that little button on the side it's not
there then you start tapping [ __ ] it's
not then you flip every light it's not
that then all of a sudden you realize
it's not plugged in you plug it in still
doesn't go on then all of a sudden you
see there's a little freaking dial on
the plug in the back of the thing behind
it with dust i'm like and then every
single lamp in the whole place has a
different way of turning it on yeah
it's basically like uh
like a riddle as soon as you get in
there turn on that yeah please continue
want to hear the wage joke i wrote on
the road yeah that i'll never do okay
because it's too old it's like who cares
it's ways
uh
this is still relevant no i use waze all
the time but i'm not gonna do a wage
joke
i'll do it here
i'm not gonna do it on stage
i mean i have a story that happened in
happened based around an uber even
though i don't like doing uber jokes but
but a story based around is different
this is just an observational joke
and say wait uh
hey waze thanks for all the updates you
think you could give me some useful ones
here i am
uh
alert
there's a paper bag on the side of the
road is it still there
how about you let me know the mcdonald's
i'm about to pull off on a highway for
has been closed for eight months
so they go vehicle stopped on the side
of the road
still there hey waze where's the not my
problem bud
yeah when did i when did i become a
consultant yeah
hello
fresh
with hellofresh you're getting farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip the trials and the trips to the
grocery store count on hellofresh to
make home cooking easy fun and
affordable
how about that it's america's number one
meal kit for a reason folks okay
i want you to savor every last second of
your summer enjoy your free time all
right and with hellofresh you can do
that because they're delivering fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than a week allowing you to
enjoy dishes delicious flavors of the
season right at home you're not wasting
time in those grocery lines you're not
going to make the trip to the store
after work you're not spending a ton of
time cooking you're getting into the
groove and get back into the fall season
right that's going to get busy that's
going to get busy not going to be summer
anymore soon folks that fall is creeping
up and fall's a wonderful season but we
all know that life kind of gets normal
again and more normal again in in the
fall maybe the boss isn't slacking off
as much as you'd like them to be so then
you can't slack off like i've been there
trust me people i'm my own boss and i'm
always hoping i slack off so that i
don't have to account
you get what i'm saying look
hellofresh is here to help all right
make those week nights when the fall
hits
fool proof with step-by-step recipes
ready in around 30 minutes or less all
right i love hello fresh i've used their
stuff i made these meals i used the kits
it's so convenient it's delivered to
your door it's all picked out for you
it's all laid out this is the thing to
do when you want time so go to
hellofresh.com tastebuds16 and use code
tastebuds16 for 16 free meals across
seven boxes and three gifts
jesus god that's hellofresh.com
tastebuds16 use code tastebuds126
for 16 free meals across seven boxes and
three free
gifts
noom man i love noom i really like what
noom is doing
uh
i am in a constant struggle of trying to
enjoy life while also losing weight
uh staying mentally healthy but having
fun
all of these things
and it's a tough balance it's a tough
balance you say you know i i want to
have the cake because you only live once
then you say i shouldn't eat the cake
because why do i do that because it's a
needless indulgence and you know at the
end of the day
this up here is tied to this stomach is
tied to the brain
and that's what noom is so great at
helping you understand helping you
figure out all right like when we decide
to lose weight it's not just about the
number on the scale all right
you want to make a change and you have a
lot of different reasons for that and a
lot of the time it's it's it's based on
psychology and that's why new
weight psychology-based approach
empowers you it empowers you with the
knowledge and support to build lasting
results lasting
that's what i like about it i've used
this service
you understand
why you eat certain foods better
they help you understand why certain
foods work better for you and i don't
mean like things like
oh eating vegetables is better than
eating bacon or whatever
you know
i'm talking about just some scientific
elements to food
that i never understood that made me
understand that's why i feel this way
after i eat this certain thing or or
it's better for me to eat this other
thing for these exact reasons
uh and and also the i know we all know
water is important but they really
hammer home
why water is important in your life and
it actually reframed my approach to
water you got water on the table right
now anyway
noom to date has helped more than 3.6
million people lose weight every journey
is different so they're giving you daily
lessons that are personalized for you
and your goals and it's a program based
on scientific principles like cognitive
behavioral therapy
uh and it's all meant to give you an
understanding of your relationship
with food noom users
or numers lose an average of 15 pounds
in 16 weeks and 95 of the customers say
noom weight loss it's a great long-term
solution so look stay focused on what's
important to you with noon weights
psychology-based approach sign up for
your trial today at noom.com taste bud
that's singular noom.com taste bud
that's
n-o-o-m.com taste bud to sign up for
your free trial
today
anyway well it would have been a great
bit when waves first came out
i love the bit you do about uh lyft i
love that bit about that it talks to you
like a guido yeah yeah yeah it's great
that's what i was out doing initially
was working on the new hour which is
almost ready and i'm very excited about
it but you know but anyway that's
besides the point um
what was i going to say okay so i go
into the hotel room in the end which i
did it i took a video of it the uh it
only had
it only had it was missing the eye on
one side of the side
so just said western in
[Music]
two heads like with no eye i go to the
room the room was so
i was so freaked out and because it had
it had a smell i slept on top of the
cover
smell yeah i slept on top of the covers
in all my clothes i've done it i've done
it i put a towel over the pillows
and then the next day i got out and i
bunched up the clothes and threw them in
the back of the car and i was like i'm
not going to wear those again no you
think it was that bad how'd you fall
asleep there was no way the pillows i
wasn't sure wait i put a towel over the
pillows
you slept on a
plus that towel was probably rough as
hell no the tower actually wasn't bad in
the and the they were bright white like
the launch the the linens in the
bathroom and i was like they
i bet the sheets were fine i just oh oh
no actually correct me
there were two blood stains oh jesus
christ little little dried washed brown
but they were there anyway let me tell
you something folks watching at home
don't do this but if you really want to
freak yourself out no matter what hotel
you're eating even if you're in a
five-star hotel you do a little
navigation when you get in there a
little inspection
pull off the uh
the mattress cover
no matter where you are look underneath
the mattress cover i'd like to
like the topper and the stuff underneath
or
even worse
take that pillowcase off
and get to the bottom of it
and uh i gotta be honest i don't do it
anymore because it's almost 100 10 10
out of 10 times you're gonna find
something displeasing
so don't subject yourself to it but i'm
just letting you know
know what you're doing when you're in a
hotel room so
i'll tell you about when i sit in a
comedy condo once and bobby kelly called
me and he goes that condo is [ __ ]
disgusting they don't wash it and i go
no it's not bad it's clean
he goes i want you to go look in the
bedroom
reach inside the pillow that you that
you're sleeping on tell me if there's a
pair of socks inside of it if there is
you know they didn't wash the sheets
there was a pair of socks no yeah so he
did that
he did it
as a test for me to see if they washed
the sheets
oh my god and i never went back to the
club ever again what club i don't want
to say out the club
it was in canada though i'll tell you
that much
what part
that'll give it away to the west
edmonton
i'm not going to say any names but
anyway listen
so i leave this place pimp asked what i
eat for breakfast every day how'd the
day start
pimp i'm not kidding
i found
in almost every city i stopped in
a place
so i went so i wake up in beaver i find
a place that specializes in biscuits and
gravy
i ate biscuits and gravy almost every
day for breakfast you could call it
mcdonald's joe it's fine
no dude this is come on man they got
biscuits and gravy this is homemade it
was sausage gravy you remember sausage
gravy and biscuits i mean come on i have
had that not too long ago actually
that's how i started almost every day
because every there were places that
just worked
portland
had tons of southern food
it was all it was all um i was just
recently there it was i mean all
southern comfort food in portland it was
crazy
couldn't you you couldn't find a healthy
meal so what'd you learn about yourself
on the road what'd you learn
well we're nowhere near that part yet
i learned that uh oh all right all right
i wanna i'm loving this i don't even i
don't even wanna stop i'm just trying to
understand where are we right now
we're about like 40.
this is a two-parter but but we're not
even gonna get to the battle i say we
finish the story in this episode and do
the battle in the next part but will
people be up in arms
we control it's joe's birthday it's my
birthday's birthday you guys don't
understand that birthday is a special
double header two hour single battle
birthday episode leading up to 40
complaints but don't
don't make it to two weeks make it a
two-hour single episode and i'll tell
you something we cannot do that we
cannot afford to do it we don't have
enough time
so we got to do an hour per week we
can't start doing two hours in a week
because then we will fall behind right
and that's that's the deal so for all of
you people and
it's your birthday boy you're making the
call no don't put it on me
this is going to rest there's going to
rest solely on the birthday boy's
shoulders this call we are i back you up
but i'm it is resting on your shoulders
so do you also was 40 minutes late today
so let's put that out there as to why we
also don't have time but we were able to
do ads during it so we really didn't
lose any time thankfully no there's nice
that i did all the ads because i've
never done that
which uh
you know all right let's let's start
wasting more time all right so let's
keep people that thought they were gonna
see
it's oh we don't even say who it was so
we could choose whatever it is no it's
mcdonald's oh yeah versus pizza hut
versus pizza hut and here is and jojo's
pizza hut no i did not how dare you um
we're gonna get to the battle he wanted
it's his birthday and his wish was to
battle for mcdonald's again
because he's only done it once about a
year and a half ago and he only brought
it up for all 90 episodes so he said
what else are you going to put because
remember you took a loss to wendy's last
time yes which was a shock to everybody
yeah uh and so i said all right fine you
want to do it i'll put a pizza hut
against you all right so here we are but
we're going to continue and this is how
we're going to do it you come along for
the ride for better or for worse this is
our journey and we're going to do a
two-part episode split into two weeks
with no battle this week promise you
this story has good parts in it
but how do we put up mcdonald's versus
pizza hut for this episode and then we
just start one just write part one i
think we just put joe's birthday
extravaganza
all right there you go
oh so this one this one doesn't even
have a battle in it there you go pimp so
this is almost like a bonus birthday
episode
no pimp's right that's how we titled i'm
doing a technique called deflect that's
how that's how we title it okay that's
right all right great birthday
extravaganza all right uh
but i wish i had one of those things
like
like the things that roll up and roll
back
yeah
what could teach you no no you're good
did you print these
no they won't give you the hats first of
all i was going to hatch off to you
for being so creative but then i was
about to say that's amazing for
mcdonald's but then i'm about to say
what are you trying to pull mcdonald's
i mean you want me to use my ink and my
paper
like what are you trying to pull here oh
you can do it at home
is it genius
i like it
then
vanity printed these off the web no
no
you printed that off the website
i bet they did that for covid
i didn't even see that holy [ __ ] that's
right can you name everybody on there
let's go mcdonald's pro
i want a t-shirt of that star me too
birdie
birdie yeah
grimace
fry guys
mayor mccheese ronald mcdonald
hamburglar obviously
um
i got to be honest i don't remember the
names of those back three the first of
all the guy in the way back the old man
i've never even i don't i don't know
that man no i know everybody but that
man uh i think he's called like
he's a cop right a stone cop or
something yeah and then the pirate the
pirate i know he was existing he existed
because i have him on a glass
he represented which food though
i don't know anybody i don't know who
the hell that guy in the back is
is the pirate holding the sword
the guy in the back looks like santa
captain
captain something has to be the pirate
okay
right
and the the the the the cop is like
he he definitely how can i not remember
that uh
officer officer big mac
look his head is a freaking big mac how
do we not get that also to officer big
mac that's a [ __ ] name yeah yeah
captain [ __ ] crow
oh he
he was the filet of fish guy yeah
but yeah i mean it's captain hook yeah
and he was loved to see and he was upset
he didn't get sued for that
no what was you okay he was the fish guy
but who's the old man keep going down
the professor what the [ __ ] is the
professor
dude
a bearded son around until 2008
now no way
no way has anyone ever heard of a
professor ever
ever i've never seen that man no no
it's a bearded scientist type character
in a lab coat from 71 to 87. all right
to 80 chevrolet mcdonald's commercials
he served as mcdonaldland's local
inventor and researcher in 83 the other
mcnugge mcnuggets became a menu item he
invented live talking delicious food
items called the mcnugget buddies all
right so he was like the guy he wrapped
the mcnuggets well he was he is the
least popular for sure
um
i see
okay
yeah if you look at these old school
pictures how scary the hamburgers are
man it's it's like it's freaky [ __ ]
you know it's yeah it's kind of like hr
puff and stuff it's like a it's like an
acid trip if what you're looking at yeah
right
it's like what but look how scary the
hamburger
literally looks like the new villain in
the movie black phone
he looks like ethan hawk i just saw that
he does look like that that's so funny
yeah the captain ain't looking too great
either yeah the cat the captain
so bring us back to the road oh sorry
yeah
so anyway so i leave beaver
most tests
most tesla charging stations i've ever
seen in my life town was lousy with
tesla charging stations
it's an odd place i don't know what was
going on what have you made it like
three states now two state was that four
no utah was the second state then i went
on to what are the b were known for
nothing i mean i don't i'm not [ __ ]
on them but like i don't think that was
like the gold rush area right okay oh
yeah maybe i don't know
i left there i went to moab i spent the
night in moab moab was great uh i ate
dinner by myself in my lab and met a guy
that used to write for rolling stone
magazine and now as a as a professional
painter meaning he paints things and
sells his art
and we were drinking together we both
were sitting alone at the bar we were
both from new york did you tell him you
had a food podcast
no
why would i
well he told you what he did
oh no he he asked what i did and i said
i'm a comedian
yeah my first line of work isn't usually
taste buds co-host
um so you didn't really share with me
but we talked for a while we drank
he was he was like he's like he can't
come where he goes you know you know lee
daniels i go the director and he goes
hey goes that guy's got one of my
paintings in this [ __ ] house
is lee daniels alive yeah he directed
yeah he directed the help and he
directed the butler and
daniels i thought he was old am i
thinking of someone else maybe daniels
jeff daniels no no buddy of mine
really uh what's he like great guy yeah
yeah nice guy really cool all right
that's good i'm not doubting it
i didn't think you don't have a beat on
the guy yeah i don't have a beat i mean
i don't it's not my you know we don't
have matching taste buds tattoos but i
can't get a beat on the guy yeah anyway
moab was amazing i drove up in the
salted mountains
yeah watch the sunset
unbelievable met an amazing old man
up like at one of the lookout points
with his wife
and that guy he said one of the most
profound things i've ever heard oh let's
take bets on what this is going to be
let's okay okay is it i know you're
trying to make fun but it was
professional swear to christ i'm not i'm
okay so
all right all right okay all right all
right i'm sorry i'm so okay so what
category would it fall the life advice
what if all of things that make you go
hmm he was literally just giving me
advice on how to watch a sunset okay and
if you were gonna photograph it what you
should do and he didn't realize how
poignant what he said to me and and how
metaphoric it was to to so to this life
journey that i was sort of okay okay
so he said something about the lens like
you're going to photograph it there's no
flash that kind of uh probably a open
lens he didn't no it wasn't lens
specific it was technique
i'll just tell you
okay tell me what he said bro then you
applied you gotta understand something
i'm on a trip oh i know i start this
trip
with the idea of
not even realizing oh my god it's
leading directly into my 45th birthday i
just got back my birthday's tomorrow
i didn't even put that together i
started this trip thinking i have to
start to understand my place in the
universe i have to stop thinking that my
life is so important
i have to stop
worrying about the [ __ ] i have to
stop worrying about what other people
have what i don't i'm gonna go i'm gonna
not do meds anymore i'm gonna start to
try to naturally face the stuff inside
of me instead of trying to mask it with
all this other stuff
i'm not knocking anybody on meds or
anything like that i've taken them for a
long time there's just a point in my
life that i got to the thing i wanted to
try right
piece of [ __ ] uh yeah i'm not knocking
any i believe in all that stuff i'm not
going like scientologist on you anyway
so i'm do i'm going i'm dealing with all
that i'm thinking about all this is i'm
driving and i'm like i love that you i
love this whole thing and i'm like i'm
going to go out on the road and be by
myself for like a week
and have immense amount of time to think
about everything
and um and and the key thing being
this little stuff and i'm by the way
i'm writing at this point
i'm writing
not writing with my hand but i'm writing
as i drive i'm using my phone recorder
and everything
and i start building like these essays
that and i'm like this would be a great
like collection of something and i was
like
i'd make a book and i could call it i
could call it i ain't [ __ ] that's a
funny title about trying to figure out
like there's so much more than me out
there and all this stuff
and you know stop and smell the roses
all that [ __ ] right and this guy when i
smell the roses i almost yeah i swear to
god
that's so funny pete holmes uses it when
i wrote on the pete holm show when i
would add when i would add like my like
take to a monologue he would go
is somebody dragging it through the
roses
i know he was like i barely know but i
feel like this is a good impression i
was like it's [ __ ] spot on
[Laughter]
basically you know old jewish woman
maybe
i almost didn't talk to this guy because
he was with his wife
they were much older than me
he had his camera
and i'm in this big black bronco with
tinted windows and i don't know anything
about what i'm doing to try to watch
this sunset up on these mountains and
i'm like i look like an [ __ ] you need
directions to watch the sun set though
because because there were so many
lookout points and they were raided and
ranked oh okay and i was like why what's
the difference if i watch from here
versus over there and i was trying to
figure it out but i didn't want to ask
this guy for help because i felt like i
looked like such a young
i felt like i looked like a punk you
know what i mean coming up with my big
dumb truck
hey where do i want to think you know
what i mean like
so i almost didn't talk to him
and he was about to drive away he had
his window up he was in a minivan with
his wife and i was like [ __ ] this this
i'm out here to try to be better so i
started walking towards his car and he
rolled down his window and he goes i
like your ride man and i was like
oh thanks and then i was like okay
he doesn't think i'm a dildo i guess
and then i said
it is insane that you the first thing
you think there's something passing an
old man and his wife is that this guy
thinks i'm a dildo i've never driven a
car this big it's got 35-inch wheels so
you're also getting used to the car
being an extension of yourself i felt
like it looked like i'm like a show off
or something i just you know get over
that
wow
no i wasn't even i wasn't i wasn't
saying that in a way i mean if that's
the way you feel off the bat you just
get used to it then you go
[ __ ] my regular car yeah anyway
so i go thanks man and i go hey you look
like you know what you're doing you got
a camera
what's where this is a good place to
watch the sunset
and i was like because these mountains
are here and i'm afraid like they're
going to block it but every lookout
point i go to i feel like there's
mountains in any direction you look like
but behind the sun was and i go are we
facing the right way and he's like no he
goes we're facing east you got to face
west
and he pointed and i go yeah man every
time i look that way from any lookout
point there's mountains
and he goes
this is what he said man this [ __ ] me
up dude he goes
well the thing is with the sunset
don't forget to look behind you
sometimes the stuff behind you is more
beautiful than this and i was like
what and he was like yeah look behind
you that's where the most beautiful
stuff is and i was like
holy [ __ ] man like this it was like it
was weird it was like meeting like an
angel or something that was like this is
what your trip is about it's about
looking
for the thing you didn't think you were
looking for
and then that was it and he drove off
that's good advice actually i never
heard that but from my own experience
when i look at the sunset from my home
the opposite it looks gorgeous where
it's setting and the sky is always like
pink and stuff but if you look the other
direction is true it casts on the city
yeah and uh the city looks insane at
that time as well
so good advice i immediately started
writing about that i was like this means
something i gotta write down
and then as i was writing that i was
like you know
p.s i couldn't see [ __ ] the [ __ ]
mountains blocked everything
which was kind of funny because you
think it's going to be this deep moment
and then you're just like oh actually
the mountains did block it right
anyway
so i then i go down to moab i meet i go
to this restaurant i meet the hardest
guy we have a few drinks i go back to
the hotel room
with him or yeah with him
uh
it's i owe him a call
i love that joe goes on the road and
becomes a beatnik author
yeah
i did miss smoking for the first time
since i quit
because you're just like it feels like
you that's what you should be doing but
anyway uh but i didn't break but anyway
so then i might have shifted off camera
i don't know
i just looked up and it doesn't look
like it's on me i'm just saying it for
i leave moab the next morning
again go to a place get the biscuits
you doubled up on the biscuits two days
in a row dude i went i think i got
biscuits four days in a row where are we
right now all the time just hit an hour
should we continue this next week
yeah why not just then it's a two-parter
do you have a cliffhanger you wanted to
make it a two-parter no we said we're
going to label joe's birthday episode
well we can oh you don't even how it's
still a two-parter
yeah do you have a cliffhanger let's get
a cliffhanger we'll just
a cliffhanger
uh the cliffhanger was what the guy told
him damn it we missed it
i saw well
i did finally
you know what
i can wrap this up give me five more
it's not that much longer
so it's not a two-part episode no no no
the next episode is just mcdonald's
versus pizza hut
this one is called joe's birthday
extravagance okay so they should have
never expected anything
no battle from the right from the get
yes because we're going to title it are
you okay
oh i'm very good you're here with us
yes
why is it that clear that what we were
doing yeah remember when pimp explained
it to you but i thought but he said four
minutes ago yeah yeah
you said we'll put part one no he said
we'll just call this one joe's birthday
extravaganza so nobody gets mad
that we didn't get to a battle in it but
we didn't even finish your birthday
extravaganza's stories so that's going
to carry over into next time i'm saying
let me i can finish this like there's
there's but if i have questions
i think it might have to carry over
maybe we just end with salty maybe you
guys just get salty do
please ya that i just thought you wanted
button it up but in an hour i could i
can get three if we can
i'm glad we're talking about this
instead of the end of the story
but here's what i'm saying right i
understand what you're saying don't say
anymore you just finish the story you
could button it up it would be joe's
birthday extravaganza no bad i can but
then in the next episode you can
continue because we still need a pream
we do preambles before the battles
sure sure so then yes then pip it's tip
okay
the button up is the man told me to look
at the things behind me
there you go that's that was the button
up that was a great out but we didn't
get out there
leave all this in
yeah
okay
nothing happened
nothing happened in denver but you're
not even halfway through the country yet
i know so much point is it was pretty
front heavy with stuff there was a there
was there was an exp i saw the sunset
finally in kansas
kansas is the opposite of utah there is
nothing
coming out now will you agree with me i
think the west coast is better than the
east coast driving
yes
so that's what happened i got to denver
i stayed with my buddy al jackson
you know nothing sorry al jackson yeah
we just we caught up it was nice seeing
him nothing crazy happened nothing
poignant we just kind of hung out
together
and i said
okay dude when i leave here and this to
me is when it really became the
adventure i was like when i leave here
it's a 14-hour shot home there is
nothing else to look at
until chicago really
and i've been to chicago many times i
love chicago but i have no reason to go
to chicago and i'm not excited to go to
chicago should i go south
should i just say [ __ ] it and go south
and al goes
go south
you're doing this do it
so i made two phone calls and here's
your cliffhanger before i went south
one was to steve byrne
and one was to willie nelson's
granddaughter
and i said will you both be in town and
they both said yes come on down
wow
next stop nashville whoa
and it picks up next week during
mcdonald's versus pizza
savolcanocomedy.com for all my tour
dates i start up again in october
there's a couple of dozen cities up
there we're going to canada we're going
to california we're going to florida
louisville evansville and everywhere in
between we just added second shows in
toronto atlanta and hershey pennsylvania
they're on sale right this second
savocanocomi.com
if you want to support the pod subscribe
to the no press channel on youtube tell
a friend rate us on itunes follow us on
spotify and merch is available uh on our
websites you can link from our
instagrams or our websites go ahead joey
jonahroza comedy uh on instagram and
twitter
joederosainfo.com for all my tour dates
i'm in atlantic city
uh i believe it's this week coming up
this weekend coming up please come out
to see that
actually also this is short notice but
if you're in new york tomorrow
tuesday
uh can i kick it me al jackson tone bell
our hip-hop comedy show where we review
old school hip-hop videos
and uh and and celebrate old school hip
hop and and really have fun doing it and
it's super funny we are doing our vice
taping we're doing a pilot with vice
tomorrow at the sultan room i don't know
if there are tickets left at this point
but check it out and maybe there are the
sunroom in bushwick yes
i love that spot you should come down do
you know about that have you ever been
there oh yeah my friend's brother owns
it that's what uh how i knew are you
kidding me i just filmed an episode
there yeah yeah of of jokers yeah it's a
great room yeah
yeah that's where we're doing it oh wow
cool um so anyway that's tomorrow and
then also there's tons more dates coming
up i got san diego
and somerville in september we've got i
think in october north carolina at the
dead crow anyway joe
jodarosainfo.com and then
joeyrosesnyc.com for all joey rose's
information there's always fun stuff
happening at joey rose's open tuesday
through sunday at 12 p.m every day come
through come see us order online we'll
see you later taste buds they coming to
the mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like two
fools gonna fight but only one food can
be right taste